une fois la nuit tombée vous commencez à
manger un peu trop vite toujours plus
vite c'est c'est comme c'est comme une
drogue
et nous accueillons notre amitié du
samedi 20h ce soir Isabelle sorange
alors Isabelle
la première vue vous êtes une femme à
qui tout réussi polytechnicienne
aviatrice patronne de presse romancière
et pourtant vous revenez de loin pendant
8 ans vous avez vécu l'enfer de la
boulimie aujourd'hui forte de cette
expérience aux limites de la folie vous
publiez chez La Teste un essai au titre
évocateur addiction générale
[Musique]
Isabelle sort entre bonsoir vous êtes né
à Marseille le 11 septembre 1970 mais
élevé à Paris dans le 16e arrondissement
vous êtes une petite fille de bonne
famille on peut dire ça on peut dire ça
votre père était commandant de pétrolier
et votre maman n'était pas obligé de
travailler
à 6 ans vous êtes scolarisé à l'école la
fontaine où vous prenez aussi tôt la
tête du classement il y avait quelque
chose pour moi de très magique dans le
fait d'apprendre et j'avais aussi
beaucoup d'amis j'ai des souvenirs de de
jeux de piste de choses qu'on a
inventées et c'était une grande période
de création et d'apprentissage qui était
pas lié à l'époque à un métier ou à
quelque chose on était trop jeune pour
pour qu'on nous dise fais ça parce que
ça te servira plus tard donc avec
quelque chose de très beau vous êtes pas
juste une bonne élève vous êtes vraiment
surdoué à l'école on peut dire ça quand
vous arrivez au collège en revanche j'ai
du mal à vous intéresser aux problèmes
des adolescents les premières cigarettes
les premiers fleurs tout ça c'est pas
trop votre truc vous tournez vers la
lecture et vous devenez une boulimique
de savoir et de connaissance on est déjà
dans l'addiction là on est déjà
peut-être dans l'excès la lecture de
Kafka a été déterminante j'ai lu la
métamorphose après j'avais aussi adoré
les Métamorphoses d'Ovide toutes les
transformations des gens qui tout d'un
coup deviennent des monstres je trouve
ça génial alors vous avez votre bac à 16
ans vous faites une prépa scientifique à
Louis-le-Grand vous êtes reçu major à
l'École des Mines mais vous choisissez
d'intégrer Polytechnique
c'est là que vous découvrez que tout ce
à quoi vous touchez se transforme
d'abord en passion et ensuite en
compulsion que ça soit la mécanique
quantique un amoureux d'origine russe ou
le poker c'est une excessive
je sais que à cette époque c'est vrai
j'adorais jouer c'était quelque chose
alors au début peut-être j'avais la
chance des débutants et je gagnais donc
et ensuite très vite j'ai perdu ce cette
chose magique et je perdais beaucoup et
pour ce qui est de la science c'est vrai
que j'attendais que
que la science m'explique tout je
pensais très très naïvement que quand
j'allais comprendre toutes ces équations
tous serait définitivement en place
alors malheureusement votre passion se
porte également à l'époque sur les
paquets de gâteaux et sur les tablettes
de chocolat ça me dérangeait pas trop en
même temps de manger beaucoup je dirais
ça s'inscrivait pas comme peut-être pour
beaucoup de femmes c'est une entrée dans
l'addiction avec la diététique de
l'apparence moi c'était pas le cas j'y
suis arrivée par un excès quoi un excès
général en fait on ne se sait pas il y a
pas une première fois dans l'addiction
c'est comme si on était déjà bien au
milieu de la de la chute et c'est au
moment où ça gronde et tout on se dit oh
là là ça fait des années que je suis en
fait dans l'addiction j'arrive pas à
m'arrêter et il est trop tard quand ça
rencontre c'est trop tard le film a
commencé on est en plein dedans alors là
toujours en quête d'adrénaline vous
faites l'école nationale d'aviation
civile et vous commencez à piloter vous
dites il y avait quelque chose en moi
que je n'avais pas contrôler j'avais
besoin de sensations fortes oui c'est
très juste c'est à dire que je préférais
les jeux réels même dangereux aux côtés
virtuel de passer toute sa vie derrière
un écran parce que quand justement on
est dans ces étudiants sages on comprend
très vite que toute sa vie on va être
censé la passer en homme trompe sans
bouger scotcher derrière un bureau
vous avez un accident dont vous vous
sortez
miraculeusement indemne à ce moment là
vous ouvrez les yeux oui c'est à ce
moment-là que je me suis dit que
juste quelque chose de
désimilé à la joie à une force de vie je
me suis rendu compte que c'était en fait
de la survie quoi un côté qui d'un seul
coup mais apparu comme dangereux et
douloureux alors là vous constatez que
vous êtes incapable de contrôler votre
besoin de manger
ça commence à vous obséder très
sérieusement une fois la nuit tombée
vous commencez à manger un peu trop vite
toujours plus vite c'est c'est comme
c'est comme une drogue quoi vous mangez
avec vos doigts vous déchirez les
cartons d'emballage pour manger plus
vite enfin c'est quoi il y a quelque
chose même de l'ordre de la possession
quoi c'est comme si le côté boulimique
ou addiction c'est le truc qui vous dit
bah non t'es pas ce petit être parfait
lisse la bonne variable économique
désolé ma chérie il y a quelque chose
d'autre quoi et il va falloir le prendre
en compte parce que ça devient de plus
en plus douloureux oui vous êtes un
contrôlable vous êtes violent vous
mangez de la viande à mains nu quoi on
peut dire que là-dedans il y avait aussi
je sentais qu'il y avait une force
immense mais j'arrivais pas du tout à se
déchaîner sur moi je me demandais ce que
c'était il y a un truc extraordinaire
dans votre histoire
c'est qu'en fait si vous n'êtes pas
rassasié vous êtes capable de descendre
dans le local poubelle pour récupérer un
reste de confiture que vous avez jeté
une heure plus tôt et ça c'est là où ça
se rapproche du junkie quoi qui qui est
prêt à tout pour avoir sa cam
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a vraiment on
pourrait dire que l'humanité se divise
en deux il y a ceux qui savent ce que
c'est d'aller jusqu'à fin à la poubelle
et les autres et là dedans il y a
quelque chose en même temps si je l'ai
écrit raconté c'est qu'il y a quelque
chose que ce genre de de situation
humiliante elle se transforme en
humanité aussi après on peut plus la
raconter qu'on est le winner vous
devenez une junkie de la bouffe quoi on
peut dire on peut dire
moi aussi ça m'est arrivé de faire des
poubelles mais pour des raisons
différentes c'est quand tu débarrasses
un peu vite des fois il y a la boulette
de chic qui tombe dans la poubelle et
forcément après sa mère
le problème en fait c'est que
contrairement au 0 innoman pour les
outre mangeurs comme on dit les
overlaters les dealers sont partout
c'est-à-dire que vous allez dans une
station-service ouverte la nuit le
dimanche il y a le supermarché dans le
métro il y a le distributeur de
confiserie c'est-à-dire que vous dis
l'heure sont partout
même pas vous faire plaindre est-ce que
vous grossissez
pas la diététique mon problème mais
quand vous allez dans les groupes
anonymes où les gens échangent là-dessus
qui sont sur le modèle des Alcooliques
Anonymes vous vous rendez très vite
compte que c'est pas l'apparence le
problème le problème c'est cette volonté
qui est qui est complètement
prise par autre chose c'est ça qui fait
souffrir la seule chose qui vous sauve
la vie en fait c'est que contrairement à
beaucoup de boulimiques vous ne vous
faites pas vomir non j'avais trop peur
de mourir j'avais peur de crever il y
avait un réflexe donc j'avais juste très
mal c'était juste douloureux et puis mon
mon ça remettait en question aussi le
pouvoir de la volonté c'est-à-dire ça ça
montre vraiment que le que la que la
maîtrise c'est un c'est un mythe que
cette maîtrise du corps cette maîtrise
de la nature qu'on nous vend partout
elle existe pas mais le savoir dans sa
chair c'est quelque chose alors cet
enfer va durer 8 ans vous vous en
sortirez par des groupes de parole
anonymes où vous rencontrez d'autres
outre mangeurs et cette grand-mère dont
vous parlez qui achète 12 croissants le
dimanche matin pour ses petits-enfants
et qu'il est bouffe avant d'arriver chez
eux quoi
cette confidence qui m'avait tellement
troublée que je m'en suis rappelé donc
je sais pas ce qu'elle est je sais pas
si elle a massacrer sa famille
finalement il y a aussi une comédienne
dont vous parlez qui se fait vomir avant
chaque casting
c'était terrible parce que en plus
souvent quand on entend ce genre de
confidence c'est des gens qu'on trouve
il y a des gens de tout âge il y a des
gens de tout sexe il y a des gens très
beaux il y a des gens qui a priori on
les dont on ne penserait jamais qu'il
souffre si on les voyait et en fait on
se rend compte que de 18 à 70 ans le
la transformation en
Mr ou Messi Hyde elle est là elle est
possible quoi la thérapie ça sera
l'écriture l'écriture d'un roman la
méditation évidemment vous lutterez
beaucoup faudra trois ans de lutte avec
des rechutes pour enfin trouver
l'apaisement quoi c'est-à-dire pour pour
apprendre à vivre avec votre manque en
fait oui c'est très important parce
qu'en fait cette partie de nous qui dit
toujours plus encore elle n'est pas
mauvaise c'est la partie qui a fait
marcher l'homme sur la Lune c'est la
partie qui nous fait apprendre ce qui
est terrible c'est plutôt l'idée de
vouloir le combler de vouloir que ça
s'arrête et donc on manque de manque
finalement en fait vous apprenez à vivre
avec votre manque sans chercher à le à
le combler vous dites j'ai réussi
déplacer l'énergie du manque vers la
création et l'écriture oui parce que le
monde se comble pas on peut le déplacer
et il s'agit de le déplacer vers quelque
chose qui soit joyeuse le problème c'est
que contrairement à l'alcool ou à la
drogue évidemment quand on est
boulimique labstinence est impossible
parce qu'il faut quand même manger alors
qu'on peut vivre sans alcool ou sans
drogue donc c'est très compliqué en fait
c'est je dirais quelque chose qui
ressemble le plus à la vie il y a une
voix du milieu à trouver c'est pas
facile une voix du milieu de la de
l'équilibre de la mesure et et c'est
quelque chose qui est j'imagine qui qui
a un chemin enfin c'est pas aujourd'hui
quand vous ouvrez le frigo qui les
plaint vous faites quoi
je regarde et j'aurais jamais pensé
d'ailleurs que ça puisse un jour mettre
égal c'est à dire que je comptais dans
les années de boulimie ces moments où il
y a plus tellement de crise ou c'est pas
mais où il y a une tension où on est au
resto sans mal à l'aise et ça
franchement je pensais pas que ça me
quitterait un ça m'a quitté tant mieux
qu'est-ce que vous auriez à dire
aujourd'hui à une jeune fille un garçon
qui vous regarde qui est boulimique pour
l'aider
pas seulement parce que aujourd'hui la
psychologie c'est vraiment les nouveaux
bigots et le truc c'est et qui se disent
que c'est une épreuve mais qu'elle a de
la valeur qui vivent ça comme une
épreuve mythologique comme quelque chose
qui va apporter du sens tout de suite
parce que si on écoute uniquement la
psychologie on se dit ah vite c'est un
problème il faut le résoudre alors du
coup ça ça résout pas la honte ça résout
rien alors que si on se dit que même ce
moment de honte d'humiliation il a de la
valeur et qu'on va la comprendre plus
tard c'est mieux
humain forcément humain Marguerite Duras
[Musique]
ça va là
c'est l'écriture c'est problématique
d'ailleurs parce qu'on ça devient trop
workout la passion le côté première
en tout cas pour l'instant c'est comme
ça
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu